EMILY ANTHES: Hi, everyone.
Thanks so much for coming in the
middle of your work day.
I'm really excited to be here.
My name is Emily Anthes, and I'm
a science journalist, and
I'm here to tell you a little
bit about my new book, which
is called "Frankenstein's Cat:
Cuddling Up to Biotech's Brave
New Beasts." The idea for this
book came to me gradually over
the course of a couple
of years.
I'm a big science geek, and
writing about science is what
I do for a living, so I spend
a lot of time reading the
science news and the journals
and press releases.
And over the period of several
years, I started noticing more
and more of these strange
headlines.
I would see things like,
"Scientists Produce
Glow-in-the-Dark Cats."
"Synthetic biology and the
rise of the spider-goats."
"Robo-rat controlled by brain
electrodes." And on and on and
on these headlines seem to go.
These headlines and many others
like them made it clear
to me that science had given us
this whole new toolbox for
tinkering with life.
We were reshaping animal bodies
in profound new ways,
altering their genetic codes,
rebuilding their broken
bodies, and supplementing
their natural senses.
So each of these stories was
interesting on their own, but
I began to wonder about
the bigger picture.
We had all these
new tools now.
How and why were
we using them?
And what did it mean for
animals, and what did it say
about us as humans that
we were making
these sorts of changes?
So I don't have time to answer
all of these questions in
detail today, but I thought what
I would do is at least
give you a glimpse into some
of the things that are now
becoming possible.
One of the things I learned in
researching this book is that
lots of the developments and
ideas that have traditionally
been relegated to science
fiction are now, in fact,
quickly becoming reality.
So obviously, when you talk
about animal modification, one
of the first things that comes
to mind is genetic
engineering.
And my adventure into the world
of genetic engineering
actually started not
far from here.
It started at the Petco
over at Union Square.
And I went there because I
wanted to buy myself a
collection of glow
in the dark pets.
It's not as crazy an idea as
it might at first sound.
Scientists, for instance, have
known for many years that
there are some creatures out
there, particularly marine
organisms, that happen
to glow naturally.
One of the most famous is this
jellyfish known as the crystal
jellyfish, and it's famous for
naturally producing what's
known as Green Fluorescent
Protein, or GFP.
This protein absorbs blue
light and re-emits it as
green, yielding the green
fluorescent ring you see
around the jellyfish's body.
In the 1990s, scientists managed
to isolate the gene
that codes for GFP.
And after they did this, they
realized they could start
moving it around the animal
kingdom, take this GFP gene
that comes from a jellyfish, and
put it into all sorts of
other critters.
That leads you to animals
like this.
This is a monkey, and only
one genetic tweak has
been made to him.
All that scientists have done is
taken this GFP gene and put
it in his genome.
As a result, his body naturally
turns out these
green fluorescent proteins, and
under a blacklight, like
what you see here, he glows
in this eerie way.
This photo has not been
altered at all.
So this kind of technology
is incredibly useful to
biologists, because not only
can they make whole animals
glow, they can engineer animals
that glow only in
certain cells or only in certain
tissues or only during
certain phases of development.
And so by creating these
animals, they get insight into
biological processes and what's
going on inside the
body of these animals.
So from a scientific
perspective, it's an
incredibly useful technology.
But about 10 years ago, some
young entrepreneurs thought
that glowing animals were kind
of cool, and maybe there'd be
a market for using
this technology
to create neon pets.
They started with this fish,
known as the zebrafish.
It's an incredibly common
aquarium fish.
You'll see them over at Petco,
most pet stores.
It's a very small
tropical fish.
It normally has these black and
white stripes, which is
what gives it its name
of zebrafish.
And it's been in use in the
ornamental fish industry for
many, many decades.
These entrepreneurs decided to
start with these zebrafish and
then to transfer fluorescence
genes into zebrafish embryos.
Not just green fluorescent
protein, but red, orange,
purple, all of the colors
of the rainbow.
When you do this, you turn
zebra fish into these.
These are GloFish.
They are America's first
genetically modified pets.
They have been on the market
since 2004, and they're now
widely available.
They're sold at most Petcos,
most Petsmarts, Walmarts.
They also come with a range of
accessories, so you can buy a
special GloFish kit.
It's an aquarium that comes
with blue and blacklights
built in, so when you turn these
lights on, it really
brings out the glow
in these fish.
So scientifically, these fish
are not very radical.
Moving fluorescence genes around
is one of the simplest
kinds of genetic engineering
that scientists do, and it's
very, very common in the lab.
But what's remarkable about
them, and why it was the first
thing I did as I researched this
book is it's really the
first biotech animal product
that is widely available to
the public.
They cost $5.00 or $6.00 a fish,
so anyone who wants to
can just walk into PetCo or
Walmart and buy themselves a
whole aquarium full of
these high tech,
next generation pets.
Of course, this is a trivial use
of biotechnology, and the
company that makes these fish
has been criticized for using
biotech for frivolous
purposes.
But once you've developed the
technology, it can be used in
all sorts of ways.
There's a lab in Singapore where
the scientist is doing
the same thing.
He is transferring
fluorescence genes into zebrafish.
But he's not creating pets.
What he's trying
to do is create
living pollution detectors.
He's managed to couple these
fluorescence jeans with
genetic switches.
So what happens is if these
fish swim in water that's
contaminated with certain
pollutants, they suddenly
begin to glow.
They switch from black and
white to these neon fish.
So that's one example of how
you can take this GFP
technology and use it in
a very applied way.
Over the course of my
adventures, I met some other
extremely useful genetically
modified animals.
I went out to UC Davis in
California, and met a herd of
genetically modified goats.
They don't look as interesting
or strange as the fish, but
they are genetically modified
on the inside.
And these go to been engineered
to produce high
levels of a compound known as
lysozime in their milk.
Lysozime is a naturally
occurring enzyme, and it has
antimicrobial properties.
What it does is bursts bacterial
cells like balloons,
essentially, and can be used to
combat e. coli, salmonella,
other sorts of diseases.
The idea is that the milk from
these goats, which is high in
lysozime, could perhaps
be fed to children.
Diarrhoeal disease is not a
huge problem in the US.
It's not something we normally
think of as a serious public
health concern.
But in many places around the
world, it's a major cause of
childhood mortality.
So it's not in human
trials yet.
It's still an animal trials.
But so far, this milk does show
some ability to promote
intestinal health and help
piglets fight off various
forms of diarrhoeal disease.
The goal would be, eventually,
to take this milk into human
trials, and perhaps to get these
genetically modified
goats out in the fields
producing milk
that anyone can drink.
Of course, you can't talk about
animal biotechnology
without talking about cloning.
That often comes
up right away.
And as it turns out, a
university in Texas, Texas
A&M, happens to have become a
leader in animal cloning.
They're an amazing university.
They've cloned six different
species of animals so far, and
they're working on
cloning more.
And so I went out to meet some
of these clones and talk to
the scientists there.
While I was there, as an
unexpected bonus, I had the
chance to meet the world's
first cloned cat.
She was created as part of a
project that began in 2000,
when a billionaire partnered
with some scientists at A&M
because he wanted to clone
his beloved dog.
When the scientists were talking
to him and working out
the details of this project,
they realized that there might
be a market for cloned pets
that went beyond this
billionaire--
that many Americans might want
to clone their pets.
So they decided that together,
they would launch a company
that would offer commercial
pet cloning services.
They called this company Genetic
Savings & Clone.
One of my other discoveries is
that animal cloners love puns
and love wordplay, and so it
is all over the field.
This is just one of
many examples.
But when they launched the
company, cats and dogs hadn't
actually been cloned yet.
So before they started selling
their services, they realized
they would need to really nail
down the technology and make
sure that it worked.
What they decided to do
first was try and
clone a cat named Rainbow.
This is Rainbow.
And the word cloning gets
thrown around a lot.
You see it in headlines and
in short news articles.
But I find that there's not a
lot of discussion about what
cloning actually means
and how it works.
So this talk isn't too
technical, but if you bear
with me for a minute, I'd like
to walk you through the
process of how the scientists
went about
trying to clone Rainbow.
They started by harvesting
some of Rainbow's cells.
But the trick is, you can't just
take a random cat cell,
like a skin cell from Rainbow,
and pop it into a new cat
uterus and expect a whole
new cat to grow.
Biology doesn't work that way.
So you need to get the DNA from
Rainbow's cells into the
proper vehicle, which
is an egg.
So after they harvested cells
from Rainbow, they recruited,
euphemistically, some
feline egg donors.
They harvested unfertilized eggs
from all sorts of other
female cats.
Then they used a tiny pipette,
which is like a small little
turkey baster, to essentially
suck out the nucleus of all of
these eggs.
So you might remember from
high school biology the
nucleus is what contains the
chromosomes and all the
genetic instructions.
So basically, what they're doing
is taking the DNA from
these eggs out and leaving
you with an empty egg.
Then they took one of Rainbow's
cells and injected
the entire cell into
the empty egg.
They put it just in
between the inner
and the outer membranes.
Then they applied an electric
current to this whole cell
within a cell system.
What the electricity does is
basically turn the cell
membranes into Swiss cheese,
poking holes in the membranes
of both the egg and Rainbow's
skin cell.
As a result, the DNA from
Rainbow's cell can flow into
the empty egg.
This sudden influx of
genetic material
actually tricks the egg.
It thinks it's just been
fertilized by a sperm, and it
will then go on to grow
and divide just
like a normal embryo.
What you end up with, then,
is a cloned embryo--
an embryo that has all
the genetic material
from Rainbow herself.
These embryos are transferred
into surrogate mothers--
other cats that have been
recruited to the project.
And if all goes well, after a
normal period of gestation,
these surrogate mothers
give birth to a clone.
Things did, in fact, go well
with the project to clone
Rainbow, and scientists
ended up with a
healthy little cat clone.
This is her.
She doesn't look very
monstrous at all.
And her name is actually CC,
which stands for Carbon Copy,
and also Copy Cat.
So again, scientists having
fun with naming.
And scientists did various
tests on her.
They found she was, in fact, a
clone of Rainbow, and that she
was healthy and seemed
to develop normally.
After her service to the
laboratory was done, one of
the scientists involved in
creating her, a man named
Doctor Duane Kraemer,
adopted her.
So when I went out to Texas,
he invited me over to his
house to visit CC, who was about
10 years old at that
point, and I eagerly took
him up on his offer.
The day did not exactly unfold
as planned, though.
When I got over there, I
naturally started to approach
the front door of the house,
and figured we'd be going
inside to meet his cloned cat.
But Doctor Kraemer and his
wife came running out and
said, oh, no no no no.
CC has her own house for her
and her husband and their
kids, was what he said to me.
And so he sort of steered me
around to behind the house
where the humans lived, and sure
enough, in the backyard
was this two story house.
We're not talking about a
little doghouse here.
This is a house that's bigger
than my Brooklyn apartment.
And so he opened the door and
let me in, and there were five
cats running around inside.
So after they'd adopted CC,
they thought she might be
lonely, and they adopted a male
cat named Smokey to keep
her company.
One of the things we do know
about clones is that they can
reproduce normally, and CC and
Smokey did go on to breed, and
had three kittens conceived
in the usual way.
Here are a couple photos
I took from the
inside the cat house.
In the first one here, this is
Doctor Kraemer, one of the
cloners, trying to
give CC a pet.
She was not very cooperative
the day I was visiting.
She spent a lot of time of
sitting out in the window
looking over what she surely
imagines to be her kingdom.
She's a very pampered cat.
There are ladders or steps here
to the second floor of
the cat house.
Doctor Kraemer also keeps all of
his students' dissertations
up there, so it's a
combination library/cat residence.
And they also build this
outside, screened-in area for
the cats so they can go out,
get some fresh air.
They don't have to worry about
the cats running off or being
attacked by some sort
of predator.
So the cat family is still
living out in Texas.
They all seem happy and healthy
so far, and Genetic
Savings & Clone did go on to
clone a couple cats for
regular American customers.
They cloned eight, I believe.
But the price was high and the
demand was kind of low, so the
company eventually shut down.
Again, you can think of pet
cloning as a pretty trivial
use of biotechnology,
and it is.
But the advances that let CC
be cloned paved the way for
other applications.
This is Ditto.
He is the world's first cloned
African wildcat.
And African wildcats are a
species of small exotic cats.
They're threatened in the wild
by habitat loss and also by
interbreeding with
domestic cats.
His name is Ditto, which is
another great pun, I guess, by
the scientists.
And he was created by scientists
in New Orleans, who
work at what's known as the
Audubon Center for Research of
Endangered Species, or ACRES.
The ACRES scientists have
really made a name for
themselves by using all sorts of
reproductive technology to
help endangered species breed.
They started with IVF and
created test tube gorillas and
things like that.
But as the technology has
advanced, so has their work.
And in recent years, they've
become especially known for
their cloning projects and their
cloning of small species
of endangered cats.
They've done four or
five of them now.
So they've just small numbers of
these cats, but the idea is
that perhaps if we can refine
this cloning technology and
really get it to work well and
predictably, that we can use
cloning to help prop up
species that might be
struggling in the wild.
There's also Bruce.
This is another animal clone.
He is a cloned bull, and was
also created at Texas A&M.
Bruce is the clone of a special
bull named Bull 86 who
was discovered in
the early 1980s.
What was amazing about Bull 86
is that he had a natural
genetic mutation that just
happened to make him resistant
to all sorts of livestock
diseases.
Because of this one genetic
error, he was resistant to
tuberculosis, salmonella,
and a disease known as
brucellosis, which is a
contagious livestock disease.
Unfortunately, Bull 86 got old
and died before the scientists
could breed him.
And though they saved some of
his sperm, accidents happen,
as they can in science, and it
was accidentally destroyed
several years later.
So for a while, it seemed like
Bull 86's valuable genes had
died out with him.
But cloning came
along in 1996.
That's when Dolly was born.
And the scientists at A&M
suddenly had an idea.
Stashed away in the very back
of the freezer was a skin
biopsy that they had taken
from Bull 86's
ear 15 years earlier.
They took the biopsy from the
freezer and used the genes it
contained to clone Bull 86.
They ended up with
this bull here.
Technically, his name is Bull
86 Squared, which, in their
scientific papers, the
scientists say stands for his,
quote, "exponential genetic
potential." But because he was
also resistant to the same
diseases, TB, salmonella, and
brucellosis, students took
to calling him Bruce.
So this is just one animal--
one bull that's been cloned,
but his birth raises
intriguing agricultural
possibilities.
Lurking out there in our herds
and flocks might be other
animals that, unbeknownst to
us, happen to have natural
genetic mutations that protect
them from disease.
So one possibility is that if we
can find and identify these
animals, we can use cloning to
create new stocks of breeder
animals and breed some
of these helpful
disease-resistant genes into
larger livestock populations.
So it's not just genetics.
We are also remaking animal
bodies from the outside in.
And in particular, advances
in veterinary medicine and
materials science are letting
us give animals state of the
art prosthetic limbs.
One of the leaders in this field
is a British veterinary
surgeon named Noel Fitzpatrick,
and he is
sometimes known as
the Bionic Vet.
He was the subject
of a documentary
series by that title.
And that's because he's become
best known for his work giving
people's pets bionic limbs--
prosthetics that are permanently
implanted into
their bodies.
The device he invented is
called the Intraosseous
Transcutaneous Amputation
Prosthesis, or ITAP, as
everyone calls it.
And that's kind of a mouthful,
but if you break down what
those words mean, you
really get a good
sense of what it does.
So osseous comes from
the word for bone.
Intraosseous means
inside the bone.
Cutaneous, from the
root for skin.
Transcutaneous means
across the skin.
And then, of course, amputation
and prosthesis.
So if we put this together,
what you end up with is a
prosthetic device that gets
inserted inside the bone and
crosses through the skin.
This on the left here is what
the ITAP actually looks like.
It's made of a titanium alloy.
That's what this rod is here.
And this longer portion here
gets implanted actually inside
of an animal's bone.
This is an x-ray of a dog who
had the bottom portion of his
leg amputated.
This smaller metal piece here
then juts out through the skin
and into the open air.
The idea is that once this
implant has been surgically
implanted and the animal
recovers, you can then pop
different artificial paws
onto and off of this
little metal peg here.
You'll also notice that there
is this sort of umbrella
shaped cap, and it's a little
hard to see, but that is also
implanted just underneath
the surface of the skin.
It's covered in all of these
little tiny holes, and that's
a crucial part of
the ITAP device.
These holes allow the device
to make a sturdy permanent
interface with the body.
What happens is the
soft tissues--
the skin, the collagen,
the muscle--
actually grows into and through
these holes, creating
this permanent link between
implant and flesh.
One of the first animals to
get one of these ITAP is a
bulldog named Cole.
When Cole was eight years old,
he developed a tumor in his
front left paw.
And the traditional treatment
for these kinds of bone tumors
is often just to amputate the
paw and to let the dog go on
with its life.
We've probably all seen
three-legged dogs, and a lot
of them get along just fine.
But not all dogs do well on
three legs, and veterinarians
were particularly worried about
Cole because he had
severe arthritis.
And so they worried that if
they took away one of his
legs, his remaining three legs
might not be strong enough to
support his fairly massive
body weight.
So they agreed to give
him an ITAP.
This is Cole a few weeks
after the surgery.
He had the device that we were
just looking at implanted.
You can see the metal peg
sticking out here, and the
rest of the ITAP is hidden away
inside his leg there.
Once he healed and recovered
from the stress of the
surgery, then his owners and
veterinarians could experiment
with different kinds
of artificial feet.
This part of the ITAP is still
sort of a work in progress.
Engineers and veterinarians are
working together to figure
out what designs of paws work
best and in what scenarios.
Here's a wide variety of the
designs that have been tried.
And in Cole's case, they found
that what worked best was
actually one of the very
low tech solutions.
This last one here is
essentially just
a rubber sink stopper.
So they popped this onto the
metal peg that came out of
Cole's foot, and this
is what they got.
This is Cole after he's
recovered from all of his
surgeries and all the procedures
with his new
prosthetic paw.
It was a huge success.
He tolerated the implant well.
It did, in fact, grow into his
skin and become a permanent
part of his body, and he seemed
to go back to life as a
normal dog.
His owners reported that most
people never even noticed he
had a prosthetic paw unless
they looked closely.
And also, before Cole had gone
through all these medical
procedures, he had been taught
some of those conventional dog
tricks, you know, where you
can say "paw" and the dog
gives you his paw.
And after all these procedures,
Cole would, in
fact, do it with either
his normal paw or
his prosthetic paw.
So he seemed to get right
back to life as a dog.
Fitzpatrick has also
done cats.
This is Oscar, and she has the
distinction of being the first
recipient of the double ITAP.
You can see both of his back
legs have been replaced here.
Oscar unfortunately had a run-in
with a mechanical grain
harvester and lost both of
his back paws, but they
gave him two ITAPs.
It's the same general procedure
that we saw with
Cole, just at a smaller scale.
I've got a short video I'll show
you here where you can
see Oscar walking around on
these paws, and Fitzpatrick
also explains a little bit
more about the design.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Come on, boy.
Come on, bud.
There we go.
Come on, man.
Here, have that bit.
Good boy.
This is a good [INAUDIBLE].
So it's now been three
weeks since we put
on Oscar's new feet.
He likes his new blades,
don't you, Oscar?
Good boy.
He also likes fish.
But he can run and jump on them
now, and his feet are
moving very well indeed.
Come on, then.
Come on, bud.
So you will have seen his
prototype feet, which were
just compressive devices.
They were devices which just had
a little spring in them.
And that was just to encourage
him to use his feet in the
first instance, and to remodel
his bone so that it built up
around the metal.
Now he's moved on to a different
phase in his life
where he needs to
be able to run.
We can see that his new
foot is like a blade.
It hits the ground like a normal
foot, and has a little
sole on it, so he can get
some traction, and
works like a seesaw.
The foot was designed so that
the metal inside his bone
couldn't break.
So if Oscar gets into
difficulty, the foot will
break here at a break point
before it would break the
implant inside his bone.
It's very much like the bindings
on a pair of skis.
So it will break off here at the
binding before it breaks
your leg, which is the
way skis work.
And we designed this implant
with that in mind.
So if you're skiing down the
hill and you catch your foot,
it will snap here before
it breaks your leg.
So that's pretty cool.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
EMILY ANTHES: So Fitzpatrick has
now done about two dozen
of these animal ITAPS, and one
of the amazing things about
them is that they've been so
successful that the ITAP is
now in human trials in Europe.
One of the first patients is a
woman named Kira Mason, and
she lost her arm in the
bombings of the London
Underground in 2005.
She had tried a variety of
different prosthetic devices
and found them lacking, and
so she signed up for this
clinical trial and got basically
the same sort of
ITAP that Cole or Oscar got.
She reports that this new ITAP
arm is much more convenient
and comfortable for
her to use.
Finally, towards the end of the
book, I get into the most
extreme territory, and I start
talking about animal cyborgs,
of which there are
now a variety.
In particular, DARPA, the
research and development arm
of the Pentagon, has been
interested in developing
remote-controlled, steerable
insect cyborgs.
And this is because DARPA has
long had an interest in
creating little tiny
flying drones--
drones that are much smaller
than the ones we tend to hear
about today.
And the idea is that these tiny
drones would maybe fly
into occupied buildings or
distant caves and perhaps
conduct surveillance--
send video or audio feeds back
to military personnel and let
us scope out a territory before
we actually go there.
The difficulty is that it's hard
to build these completely
mechanical drones at
a very small scale.
Partly that's because the
dynamics of flight change when
you get that small.
And there's also a
battery problem.
These drones are so small and
light that they can barely
carry any weight, and as a
result, the batteries they do
carry tend to be
very low power.
They only keep these drones
aloft for a couple of minutes.
So DARPA realized that maybe
insects would be a shortcut to
these kinds of drones.
After all, they already know
how to fly, and better yet,
they power themselves.
All we'd need to figure out how
to do is to steer them and
make them obey our commands.
So in 2006, DARPA put out a call
asking researchers across
the country to submit proposals
for how they would
create these kinds of
insect cyborgs.
DARPA funded a couple
of these proposals.
One of the scientists who won
funding is a man named Michel
Maharbiz, and he's
at UC Berkeley.
He decided he was going to work
with these flour beetles.
They're relatively
large beetles--
three or four inches--
so they're bigger than
most insects.
The trouble is that Maharbiz is
an electrical engineer, and
he knew plenty about the wiring
and the circuitry, but
next to nothing about
insect biology.
So to begin with, he started by
delving into the literature
and trying to figure out
what we knew about how
these things fly.
He ended up homing in on two
areas of the beetle brain at
the base of each optic
lobe, here and here.
And the literature suggested
that these areas of the brain
were involved in flight
initiation and cessation.
So he tinkered around in his lab
and decided he was going
to hack into these
brain regions.
He ended up threading thin wires
into the base of each
optic lobe.
The wires then snaked out of
the brain and connected to
this circuit board.
Then, at the back of the circuit
board here, you see a
big radio antenna.
The scientists wrote specialty
software, which they called
Beetle Commander, and they could
sit with their laptops
across the room 100 or more
yards away from the beetle and
start issuing commands
with this software.
The commands would be picked
up by the radio antenna,
transmitted into the circuit
board, and then electrical
pulses would go zinging down
these wires and into the
beetle's brain.
Through trial and error, they
discovered that if they sent a
series of rapid fire electrical
pulses into the
beetle's brain, it would
suddenly take flight.
On the other hand, if they sent
a single long pulse to
the same area of the brain, the
beetle would immediately
stop flying.
The effect was so dramatic
that the beetle would
literally fall out of the
air in mid-flight.
And you don't have to take my
word for that, because you
will see that in this video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
The beetles were not injured,
by the way.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
EMILY ANTHES: So that's
pretty dramatic.
But of course, that's
just step one.
In order to actually be useful,
the beetles need to
not just stop and start, but
go in the right direction.
And so the next step was to
figure out how to take control
of the beetle's movements
while it was in the air.
The scientists managed to
do this by adding a
second set of wires.
It's not in this photo,
unfortunately, but they went
to the base of the beetle's
wings on each side.
And what they discovered is that
when they stimulated the
right wing muscle, the right
wing would start beating with
more force, and as a result,
the beetle would naturally
veer to the left.
And vice versa, by stimulating
the left wing muscle, the
beetle would veer
to the right.
I have another video of that.
I'll warn you in advance, it's
a little harder to see than
the previous video, but you can
see definitely the beetle
veering across the room.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So I think I'll stop it there.
You guys the idea.
It's a little difficult
to see.
But this is a pretty dramatic
thing to do, to take control
of this beetle's movements.
But it's still pretty crude.
So right now, all we're able to
do is make them veer in one
direction or the other.
In order to really be useful,
we'll need to take much more
precise control.
Military commanders may want
the beetle to go left by 40
degrees while flying at a
certain altitude and speed.
So that's something that the
scientists are working on now
is to make much more fine-tuned
commands that they
can control the beetle with.
So obviously, some of these
things are very radical things
to do to animals, particularly
when you talk about taking
over their nervous systems, and
it's easy to understand
why some of these technologies
are controversial.
It can certainly, in certain
cases, cause animal suffering.
It can turn animals into
commodities or tools.
And in certain cases, it could
potentially pose a risk to us
or to the environment, to
ecosystems that we all share.
These are absolutely serious
issues, and they deserve
serious consideration.
There is plenty of reason to be
cautious as we move ahead
with these technologies.
I think we need more of a
societal discussion about how
we want to use these
technologies, and
why, and to what end.
And we should absolutely
be prepared to reject
applications or products that
pose undue dangers.
But I also think there's a lot
of reason for hope, and animal
biotechnology could do more good
not just for the world,
but also for animals themselves,
than it's often
given credit for.
Biotechnology, after all, is
not inherently good or bad.
It's merely a set of techniques,
and we have
choices about how
we can use them.
What scares me a little bit
is that if we have these
knee-jerk reactions against
biotechnology, then we'll lose
many, many of the good
beneficial applications along
with the bad.
So thank you guys
for having me.
I know we don't have a lot of
time left, but I'm happy to
take questions.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I hear there are
glowing plants on Kickstarter.
Have you seen them?
What is your sentiment
about them?
EMILY ANTHES: I have
seen them.
So the question is, there's a
Kickstarter campaign to fund
the creation of glowing
plants.
And actually, that's
not a particularly
radical thing to do.
So scientists have created
glowing plants in the lab.
But one of the things that's
become controversial about
this project is that one of the
rewards for donating is a
set of these seeds,
supposedly--
these glowing plant seeds.
So a big concern with
genetically modified organisms
is what happens if they
get loose in the wild?
And so I think the plants
are likely to
be completely harmless.
I'm not worried about human
safety or, if someone ate
them, food safety.
But I think it's a little bit
worrisome that we might see
all these seeds going
out there in a
totally unregulated way.
So I think that's why it's
gotten so much attention.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering
with the cloning to save
animals that are dying out, if
every animal is a clone, how
would the population not end
up just being interbred?
Is that something that--
EMILY ANTHES: Right.
So cloning is not a cure-all,
and sometimes it's presented
as, well, all we have
to do is make more
copies of these animals.
Problem solved.
I think that's an exaggeration,
but I think it
can be useful in much
more limited ways.
So as you, I think, were getting
at, one of the big
problems with endangered species
isn't just that they
are small in number, but they
lack genetic diversity.
And so cloning, obviously,
doesn't solve that problem,
because it only gives you
replicas of the animals you
already have.
But it could potentially be used
to keep diversity from
dwindling further.
So if you have animals that die
before they can reproduce,
or are infertile for some
reason, or something else
happens, you could potentially
take cell samples and clone
them and at least sort of get
those genes back into the
population.
There's also a big effort right
now with frozen zoos--
like tanks of liquid nitrogen
where scientists are storing
cells and DNA from all sorts
of wild animals.
And I think there's real
potential there, because if we
have a species that, say, now
looks OK, but in 50 years is
endangered, and the genetic
diversity has died off, we may
have these samples of genes that
have disappeared and can
perhaps clone them back
into existence.
So I think in this limited
way, it could be useful.
But yes, we're not going to save
species just by making
thousands of clones.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: On a kind of related
topic, I saw on "60 Minutes"
maybe a year ago that they found
some dinosaur DNA, and
they were actually, for real,
legitimately trying to
actually bring some
of them back.
What's your perspective on
that, and do you know
anything about it?
EMILY ANTHES: I haven't
seen that.
I mean, the perspective of every
scientist I've ever seen
is that dinosaurs will
never be possible.
Not only cells degrade over
time, but DNA begins to
degrade at the moment
of death.
And so I've not seen
anyone say that.
The DNA is just too far gone.
The moon shot project right now
is the mammoth, which is a
lot more recent than the
dinosaur, and it's still
unclear whether we will have
good enough DNA, even these
best preserved samples, and
you probably saw just last
week, I think, they found an
amazing preserved sample.
But so far, the DNA is
still in fragments.
The cells are deteriorated.
So, I mean, scientists are
still hoping, but it's--
to excuse the pun--
a mammoth project.
It will take not just taking a
cell and popping it out and
cloning it, but we'll have to
painstakingly reconstruct what
we think the mammoth
genome looked like.
And so even that's a
bit of a stretch.
But dinosaurs really seem
like an impossibility.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: For the mammoth
project, though, what species
would we use as a host?
EMILY ANTHES: The discussion
is the elephant, which--
AUDIENCE: Is sufficiently
close?
EMILY ANTHES: Well, we don't
know, and I don't
think we will know.
And there are also questions,
I think, about whether, even
if we can do it, it's
fair to do it.
At least my thought is that
the ecosystems for these
animals have disappeared, and
the earth is so radically
changed that what would we do
with these mammoths when we
brought them back?
Would they just live in zoos?
Would it just be for
our own amusement?
Just personally, my perspective
is I would rather
see this technology used to try
and keep the species we
have now from dying out, rather
than trying to bring
back species that have been
gone for a long time.
But others disagree with me.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You said one of the
reasons that Genetic Savings &
Clone went out of business is
because it was too expensive.
Is the cost coming down
for this technology?
EMILY ANTHES: The cost
of pet cloning has
not come down a lot.
I don't know of any commercial
cat cloning companies in
existence, but there are two dog
cloning companies in South
Korea, and it's $100,000 to
$150,000 still to clone a dog.
But there are some companies in
the US that are banking on
it coming down, and
they actually will
store your pet's DNA.
And their whole business model
is when cloning gets better
and cheaper, then you
can clone your pets.
We'll see, I guess.
Did you have a follow up?
AUDIENCE: I think I saw
that CC with different
colors than her clone.
Is that a disappointment for pet
owners to realize they're
not exactly the same?
EMILY ANTHES: Yeah.
I talk about this in the book.
I didn't get into it here.
But if you were watching
closely, you'll notice that CC
was grey and white, and
Rainbow was gray
and white and orange.
And it turns out that calico
cats in particular are not
great candidates for cloning,
because the genes for grey
versus black fur are on one X
chromosome, and the gene for
orange fur on another
X chromosome.
So in calico cats, depending
on which X is active in a
cell, you either get a patch
of black or orange.
But when you clone, scientists
suspect that what happens is
the cell they used from CC had
the X chromosome turned off in
that particular cell,
and as a result, CC
didn't express any orange.
The entrepreneurs were not happy
about this, because they
thought people would realize
that they might not be a twin.
The scientists didn't do this
intentionally, but were really
happy to see that CC didn't
look the same.
One of their concerns has been
that pet owners might
misunderstand the technology
and think they're getting
their same old pet back.
So for them, they use this
example a lot to remind people
it's not the same animal.
But calico cats, you're always
going to run that risk in
particular.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What effect does the
mitochondrial DNA have on this
whole process?
EMILY ANTHES: So that's the
other thing that you don't
hear talked about very
much in cloning.
So remember I showed you when
they take the egg and they
suck the nucleus out, that's
99.9% of the genetic material.
But mitochondria, which are
these little organelles that
sit in the cytoplasm, have their
own tiny little genomes.
And so technically, clones
aren't quite perfect copies of
their genetic donors, because
they have the mitochondrial
DNA from their egg donors.
Most scientists sort
of wave that off.
Because it's so specialized and
small, they tend to not--
maybe it will have a slightly
different energy metabolism,
but because it tends to not
have physical, visible
effects, scientists don't
really talk about it.
But, you know, it is a small
complicating factor.
AUDIENCE: It would
definitely make
ancestral analysis confusing.
EMILY ANTHES: Yes.
One of the issues with cloning
endangered species is because
if you have a leopard and you're
trying to clone it, you
don't want to put all these
other endangered leopards
through surgery to harvest
their eggs.
So they tend to use eggs from
domestic species, like
domestic cats.
And so there's an interesting
philosophical question you can
ask about if it's a jaguar,
we're reproducing these
endangered species, but it has
a tiny little bit of DNA from
a different species, are we
really continuing the lineage
of the same species?
And that's a debate that
ecologists are having.
And it's an interesting
philosophical question.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned that one
of the Xs was turned off,
and that's why the clone
looked different.
Is it possible that if
you were to use--
I'm not sure what cells were
used initially, if they were
skin cells or something else,
but if you used stem cells,
would that make a difference?
EMILY ANTHES: You
know, it could.
One of the problems with a lot
of this work is that so few
animals of any one species have
been created that there's
not a lot of data
to work with.
I don't believe that's
something that
scientists have tried.
I mean, the idea is when you
clone, that if you take DNA a
from a skin cell, it's what's
known as differentiated.
It's specialized to
be skin cell DNA.
And in theory, when you put it
in the egg, it's supposed to
get reset to the embryonic
state.
But that doesn't always happen,
and sometimes it
happens partially.
And so it's a question of how
well we do at getting the DNA
to sort of reset to its
normal settings.
And that's thought to be one
of the reasons that clones
sometimes have birth defects or
die in the womb is because
if the DNA doesn't get
reprogrammed correctly, it may
not be viable.
AUDIENCE: So is the other X on
anywhere else in the clone?
So if the clone is female, and
there were two Xs, and one of
them was turned on and the other
one was off in the cell
that was shot into the embryo,
so did they do any tests to
see if any other parts of the
cat were [INAUDIBLE]?
EMILY ANTHES: They didn't.
And, I mean, X inactivation is
sort of their best guess for
why she didn't have any orange
was that for each individual
cell, a different X chromosome
can be on.
And so, in theory, it could have
turned out that some of
the orange Xs were
on in some cells.
But they didn't really look
into it in detail.
Their guess is that, for
whatever reason, the DNA
didn't reset, and so in all the
cells, that X chromosome
was inactive.
But it's not clear.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] stupid
question, but how does
it work with men?
Because it sounds like with
using genetic material from a
female animal and plugging that
with more female-- does
cloning actually work in
the male instance?
EMILY ANTHES: Yeah, it does, but
if you clone a male cat,
you'll get a male cat.
If you clone a female cat,
you'll get a female cat.
And men have mitochondrial
DNA, it just
comes from their mothers.
So you can clone either sex.
Any other questions?
Thank you guys for coming.